so those kids growing up in Gaza
now to you they have almost no choice
but to have
hatred for
Israel it's
human I mean look any
child that is under that type of
Oppression is going to hate their
oppressor I don't care who you are I
don't care what you are but here's my
problem with how that gets brought
up
you're talking about the future of the
security of Israel even some people that
speak about it uh seemingly from a place
of being well-meaning that say the only
way that Israel can have its Security is
to stop killing Palestinians and so the
future of Israel depends upon
Palestinians not hating Israel so much
and so we've got to stop tormenting
these people so that they don't grow up
to want to torment us you've already
decided then whose life is worth more
than the other and so instead of talking
about the future of Israeli Lives why
don't you talk about the present of
Palestinian lives instead of talking
about whether or not your state will be
secure in the
future talk to me about why you're
killing children now 2third of the
30,000 civilians are women and children
and so uh we can't talk about what these
children are going to grow up with we
should talk about whether or not these
children are going to grow up in the
first place and that should be what
dominates our conscience right now and
what drives our policies and what drives
our emotions right
now